let me talk to you about now let me come
in I'm on vacation okay you got your
prospective hello this is Gary
Vaynerchuk oh my god how are you I'm
good I'm good
I was just watching you oh my god what's
your name mm-hmm just before Jeffrey for
New York yeah my guy anything I can
answer for you yeah
so I'm like in the like I get it but I'm
trying to like push like looking at all
the time I put to the doing part so like
my uncle he has a car dealership right
now and I get them marketing it's just I
don't know where to start because I'm
not like so into mark you know right now
I just know I just know just by watching
you all what to do I just don't know how
to start with him when you say you get
it but you don't know what to do does
that mean theoretically at the macro you
understand that marketing works but you
don't even a tactically execute it or do
you don't know how to convince him to
let you tactically execute it no he
wants me to do it I just don't know like
where to start of like I know I should
start a Facebook page and stuff like
that but as far as like with because he
had like a small shop he doesn't have
like a big shot all right I'm gonna go
you're like you you you you got a pan or
you got your phone to write this down
like I'm gonna give you a URL I'm gonna
make you read this 86 page deck you
ready it's Gary its I put out an 86 page
deck that explains the secret yeah have
you gone through it oh no good that's
what you want to do you want to go
through that free content model and then
execute against it and look at it and do
that all right
and then for what if I have like my my
parents like just forced me to go back
to school like should I still like worry
about that just focus on is trying to
help my uncle
well why that is
tabret that makes sense break this down
for me why would you listen to your
parents I'm not I'm not saying that as a
joke I'm saying yeah you live in their
house and you have to like like I'm
always fascinated by why one would
listen to their parents the two reasons
that people would listen to their
parents are one they live in their house
or their or their parents are giving
them money and they need that roof or
money to they just deeply love their
parents and they're just scared to let
them down
do you have a bad one you have is yours
one is a 2 is it a mix it's like a mix
of like one because it's like like I'm
less out of ways okay so out of my mom
so when I was 18 okay and I had my own
apartment since 19 to 21 right now but
because of because of a health issue
yeah I had to move back sorry so not she
were hers my okay are you better now
head out
yeah I'm better now good but it's just I
want to go back to like being on my own
but it's just the fact that like now I'm
living with her so it's like she wants
me to do what I want to do but then
again it's like you know that always you
know you got to go back yeah yeah she
bought into the propaganda like
everybody else look honestly I don't
think you should go back to school right
and that's why I keep telling because
it's like listen the biggest thing I
want you to do straight up is start
flipping and making money right like
mom's crib in like five minutes if you
just went to the thrift store the dollar
store eBay Kmart Walmart like like
unless and that's what I did - uh did
the whole EB thing I was doing good it's
just right there you know when you see
one shipping and all that stuff like
that's how you really things yeah
charger my man you're giving me all the
cliche answers
charge charge shipping work 18 hours a
day you know how you make normally
people like your Gary Vee I made $3,000
on ebay this month how do I make more
like
which can you work there like like I
don't know like nine hours I'm like cool
work 18 hours work 36 hours work 72
hours 140 face what Julie I'm just
worried in my head do ya dude just
honestly stay right there you just
cracked it and if I can get you to
actually believe it not just saying
you're in your [ __ ] head
you're debating you're playing life in
your head not actually living it right
and that's what I hate it's like I know
is that good to do it just like that
push like I don't want to wait till
something bad happens you are though you
know the bigger question is why the
bigger question is this is why I got
myself into the hole do you give about
other people's opinions you know right
the biggest thing the other people get
caught up on is like they'll make 400
bucks flip it and then they'll go buy
some whites yeah and and that and that's
the theme to look like I don't want to
be caught up in that my class started
just I bought I made my own search so I
just wear my shirt there's a good boy
I'm not sure I like the person that
flosses last wins it's the reason you
reacted that way is because everybody's
playing at the reverse right I was in it
i an't i flossed in my 20s I didn't buy
anything I didn't go out I didn't do
anything
yeah and I'm foundation and then that's
the thing that I learned from you is
like I starts to rely like damn don't
really need to go to the club really
need to go to that gorge and you know
I'll tell you what happens now you know
now you watch a little Gary Vee you get
a little motivated you decide to
actually work on Friday night but then
you wake up Saturday right and you're
feeling good and then you grab your
phone and you go on Instagram and the
first thing you see is your boys are the
people that you look up to in the club
pretty girl
Jewellery mark and Imani and all of a
sudden you're FOMO yeah yeah I think I
think I get a little bit of that blade
slide try not to like worry about it
because it's like dinner I carry be
motivated in me but then I got my mom to
let me go back to school like that like
your mom's in the middle so what college
and get no job because of it let me talk
to you about it yeah
now let me run out come in I'm on
vacation okay they're coming here
they're spending one day here you're
coming here you're coming to me no video
one day I'm gonna put you with the crew
I need to get you rewired all right Gary
at vaynermedia see how what I put in the
title say I'm dude that's gonna get me
wired I'm antsy that's a great way those
one more phone calls always work out I
want that whole video on YouTube
yo Instagram what you think but what's
amazing about that is that phone call is
90% of it and by the way everybody who's
like razzing in the comments that's just
his way of communicating valley girls
got that yeah that's like bro dude frat
dudes got that like like emo dudes got
that like yeah he did it like in the
culture urban dude voice and terminology
and vibe but don't judge everybody
because all of you are doing the same
your way a lot of skiing dudes doing
this like don't judge everyone
99 I'm watching I'm watching you and 99%
of you are playing that same game you
may use different adjectives different
terminology you might have different
kinds of friends and circumstances but
in your dome and your framework and your
execution that's you
ninety-nine percent of you and we're
gonna smoke you now in 2019 see ya
oh yeah subscribe like and comment I
don't even do the best practices on
YouTube
oh we will thank you dear rock subscribe
like and comment
bunchy watching comment content and
you're not subscribed the amount of you
that IDM the bunch of like cool people
and they're all like huge fans I'm like
you don't even follow me instrument even
know you knew like the amount of you
watching or listening right now that
like I know this is gonna be a podcast a
madam you were listening the podcast
right now and you're not subscribed to
the podcast so you get pinged in the
morning is ludicrous this is the year of
subscribe comment share rate and review
too and pass on to a friend that is
confused about what's going on over here
that's right all of you have a Gary Vee
hater in your life grab their hand and
hunt them bring them over here see ya
[Music]